[Musique]
heureusement que ça se voit pas quand je
rougis
écoutez on a une présentation comme
celle-là
champion du monde en menant c'est 51
combats attention
depuis 2014
on se bisou sur le biceps
mais la question qui vient après c'est
et ensuite on en fait quoi
ça c'est une question qui m'est venue
très très vite surtout que de par mon
expérience j'ai rencontré des
championnes et des champions de leur
quotidien qui m'ont permis de réaliser
et de me réaliser
j'ai réalisé qu'en fait chacun et
chacune d'entre vous ici à son propre
championnat tout comme ma mère avait son
championnat qui était qui consistait
d'élever ce gaillard là mais après ce
que 5 kg et qui aujourd'hui après de 115
kg tout comme mes coachs
qui s'amusent à révéler les potentiels
des personnes ou tout comme ces
étudiants qui a pas très longtemps
Ariane passer leurs examens tout en
organisant cet événement qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui en fait chacun a
son championnat
et je me suis retrouvé très très vite à
me rendre compte qu'en fait il y avait
des champions du quotidien qui eux
n'avaient pas ce côté lumière et under
the post de Spotlight et d'ailleurs je
vous pose une question d'ailleurs si je
vous dis je suis non tu es champion tu
es championne qui ose lever le point ici
qui ose le point ok gardez le point levé
s'il vous plaît
je vais faire juste un petit challenge
parce que avant tout moi je suis pas
venu pour me présenter je suis venu ici
pour pour vous rencontrer d'accord donc
gardez le point levé
tout le monde va fermer les yeux
et je vais vous poser des questions au
fur et à mesure si vous connectez à ce
que je vous dis si je vous reconnaissez
dedans vous lèverez le point ok pour
vous alors on ferme les yeux on garde le
point le vœu pour ce qui est celles et
ceux qui avaient le point levé alors
est-ce que tu as des défis à relever
est-ce que tu es confronté à des échecs
est-ce que tu es confronté à prendre des
décisions en situation changeant est-ce
que tu es amené au quotidien à devoir
prendre des décisions alors que t'as pas
tous les paramètres est-ce que tu dois
entreprendre ta vie est-ce que tu es
amené des fois à aller au-delà du regard
de l'autre au-delà du doute de l'autre
est-ce que tu es amené toi aussi à te
dire j'aimerais bien faire telle chose
mais j'ai pas la bonne situation j'ai
pas la bonne personne ouvrez les yeux
autour de vous ouvrez ouvrez
vous pouvez vous applaudir
c'est devenu une mission de vie pour moi
alors c'est parti tout
vous voulez savoir comment ça s'est
passé mon premier Championnat du Monde
oui
lui combat dans l'année dans une
discipline où il y a pas forcément la
télé alors le chaos du comme dans un
film je mets un coup la personne tombe
sur la table des arbitres alors qu'au
début j'étais au sol super j'ai pas payé
mon loyer depuis 4 mois je me dis waouh
là ça déconne
je remporte le combat au bout de 6
minutes on me lève la main et rien
rien j'ai rien ressenti
je me retrouve dans ma chambre alors le
monde du sport désolé hein c'est
peut-être
Idy pour certains mais je dis non
pom-pom girl ni à qui que ce soit
personne range je veux rester seul il y
a un truc là qui manque c'est que je
j'ai rien ressenti bon j'avoue c'est un
peu content parce que j'avais déçu ce
qui avait mis dans leur pronostic ma
défaite le français ne pouvait pas
devenir champion du monde et ainsi de
suite tout ce que vous nous connaissez
avec notre rapport avec la réussite et
là je me dis mais là tu es champion et
donc et alors et ensuite
et ensuite
et là je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait
au-delà de la performance il me fallait
du sens je fais ça pourquoi
pourquoi je fais ça en fait alors le
gouffre il a été abyssal quand j'ai reçu
ma prime je vais pas vous en parler ici
parce que là il fait tard de vous
assommer
d'où savait venu cette quête de sens en
fait au-delà de la performance d'où ça
m'est venue le fait de me dire bah tiens
il faut que je sois dans le cherche à
être meilleur au lieu de chercher à être
le meilleur vous voulez savoir ça
alors accrochez-vous je vous raconte
cette histoire là personne n'a le
monopode la misère aussi mais ça remonte
à l'enfance l'histoire elle est assez
profonde elle est assez spéciale mais ça
a été ma première connexion avec la
notion de visualisation il y a 20 ans
qu'on parle visualisation de préparation
mentale c'était pas le cas c'était pas
quelque chose qui était très anodin et
très commun ça a été ma première
connexion avec le fait de passer de
d'être coupable responsable ça a été ma
première connexion avec la notion de
d'être discipliné d'avoir des rituels
donc ça se passe comme ça j'ai 8 ans une
dispute parentale comme il peut y en
avoir je pense qu'ici on est plus d'une
personne à se disputer qu'on a en binôme
en couple
j'ai pas demandé de lever la main qui
et là ma belle-mère
sort donc je suis avec mon frère on est
au salon elle sort elle se dirige dans
ma dans ma chambre mais elle sort une
phrase
qui m'avait agacé sur le moment il me
dit je me suicider
et moi je réponds bah vas-y
voilà on est devant la télé vous savez
quand on est devant un écran on est
concentré quoi bah vas-y et là se dirige
vers ma chambre si tu vas faire dans ma
chambre il y a une fenêtre
donc je vois cette dame enceinte qui
monte
je la suis avec mon frère
et à se jette
est-ce que
et l'action elle a dû être très rapide
mais moi ça m'a paru très très long je
me dis mais qu'est-ce que je viens de
faire et toute une combinaison de choses
là je vous en parle j'ai encore désolé
et j'y vais
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est encore les
yeux ouverts et qu'elle me regarde
trois jours plus tard trois jours plus
tard je suis seul dans cette chambre
papa il est déjà en train de travailler
là il y a personne
je me sens coupable je me dis bah tiens
il faut que j'aille lui demander pardon
parce que là j'ai vraiment vraiment
exagéré
là il y a personne donc je vais faire ce
que j'ai à faire je me mets sur le
rebord de la fenêtre
écoutez bien je vous ai raconté cette
histoire pour vraiment vous vous preniez
conscience de comment on peut prendre la
décision la plus importante de sa vie
et je m'exerce comme si je me préparais
à me jeter je me mets comme ça
une deux et avant de me jeter
je regardais quand même je vous disais
ça peut faire mal quand même mais au
moins on serait quitte
et là j'ai un tas d'image qui me
viennent en tête alors ne me demandez
pas comment il y a pas de données
scientifique là dessus j'ai Caroline et
Charles Ingalls alors ça va vraiment
monter qui me viennent en tête j'ai
Sangoku vous voyez ce personnage de
dessin animé là qui est super fort qui
pourrait détruire la Terre et qui a peur
de sa femme quand il rentre à la maison
j'ai ce fameux dessin animé qui
s'appelle il était une fois la vie avec
ce barbu qui t'explique que si tu bois
du lait il y aura du calcium et que il
faut faire du sport pour devenir costaud
et je me dis mais et si je décidais de
vivre pour quelque chose au lieu de
mourir pour rien
alors là je ressors et je là j'en
retombe parce que voilà c'est frais
c'est la première fois que je parle de
cette histoire comme ça en public
Jason tremblotante je m'assois
je pars dans le frigo chercher un verre
de lait parce qu'il a dit qu'il fallait
boire du lait
et là je me dis je vais tout faire pour
être meilleur je vais tout faire pour
que comme on m'a dit que son âme était
aussi avec elle me voyait toujours que
son âme perçoivent le fait que je
cherche à être meilleur et ça a été ma
première connexion avec le fait de
rentrer dans cette dynamique d'oser être
meilleur là je faisais mes pompes je
buvais mon lait les ponts ça a
fonctionné vous voyez tu vois là-bas ou
pas
et on voit qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
qu'on peut aller chercher dans l'enfance
comme ça
vous comprendrez aussi pourquoi quand
j'ai grandi j'ai pas mal de d'actions et
d'investissement que j'ai pu avoir
auprès de la cause qui concerne les
enfants ou ne serait-ce que d'essayer de
motiver des décideurs qui en boulot très
très contraignant à ne pas faire partie
de ceux qui se disent le lundi vivement
vendredi et qui vont en mettre plein la
vue quand il rentre le soir et qui vont
se défouler parce qu'ils passent leur
temps à faire des choses qu'il n'aime
pas et qui n'ont pas de sens
comprendrais pourquoi je suis allé dans
cette voie là donc ça ça a été mon
premier contact avec la visualisation le
fait de me responsabiliser ne nous
culpabiliser au lieu de me dire bah
tiens il s'est passé ça moi aussi je me
détruire il s'est passé ça je vous donne
le compte l'opportunité de construire
attention là aujourd'hui je mets les
mots mais il faut savoir que ça a mis du
temps
il faut savoir qu'il a fallu du temps je
viens d'une époque où quand tu allais
voir le psy ou le thérapeute était un
fou
d'accord donc maintenant
on arrive et je vous ai parlé du mot âme
et ça m'a donné ce concept autour de
oser être meilleur qui se résume en
trois lettres ama aujourd'hui ça
repousse là dessus c'est là-dessus que
repose mes interventions quand je
m'adresse à des personnes le a de
attitude
c'est à dire je veux développer quelque
chose qui me permet d'avoir un impact
sur quelque chose sur lequel je donnais
aucun contrôle quelqu'un se jette un
accident niveau climatique ainsi de
suite autour de l'attitude je vais
pouvoir avoir un impact dessus il a un
direct le M
pour méthode
méthode
par à tout à l'heure
donc
je voudrais faire une petite parenthèse
parce que qui peut se prétendre oser
être meilleur je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure personne avait le monopole de le
monopole de la misère vous avez des
personnes qui vont dire mais toi c'est
parce que tu as vécu ça que tu es comme
ça
est-ce que il faut absolument avoir vécu
des choses dramatiques pour prétendre
être dans ce concept d'oser être
meilleur or je réponds par une question
est-ce que vous seriez serein si vous
croisiez votre pilote et qui vous dit et
qui vous disait moi je suis légitime
parce que je suis celui qu'elle record
du nombre de crash
est-ce que vous seriez serein si vous
voyez quelqu'un qui ce qui un jockey qui
s'entraînerait à quatre pattes en se
disant mais moi je peux pas être un bon
jockey tant que j'aurais pas été un bon
cheval
ou quelqu'un qui arrive avec la tête
vous savez un peu déformé qui se dit bah
moi pour être un bon boxeur faut que je
sois un bon punching-ball c'est pas du
tout dans cette dynamique là qu'il faut
être vous avez des personnes qui parlent
empathie leur capacité à au service qui
se passe dans la vie arrive à rentrer
dans ces dynamiques d'oser être meilleur
donc ça c'était la petite parenthèse
mais revenons-en à Amma le a de attitude
il m'est venu et là j'ai trois petites
anecdotes pour vous
la première
avec ma mère ma Simone Veil à moi
je suis avec cette femme qui se met à se
mettre dans la transmission et qui me
tenait des longs discours mais je pense
que je suis il y a plus d'une personne à
qui ça a dû arriver de discuter avec
l'un des parents et que vous soyez là en
train de vous dire mais c'est quand
qu'il a fini qui est dans ce cas là ici
qui a déjà vécu ce truc là
il me parle j'étais là dedans moi je
chantais dans ma tête Enoc tu sais vu
comment tu es gentil comment tu es
serviable avec maman jusque là ça allait
mais j'avais peur du vaisselle bon
et ben quand tu seras grande sera beau
jusque là ça va
elle était beaucoup d'intransmission je
sentais qu'il y a quelque chose qui
allait pas elle me dit et tu seras beau
et tu vas plaire aux femmes d'accord moi
je pensais vous savez avoir mon scooter
avoir un chien je pensais pas du tout à
ça elle me dit tu mettras la capote
voilà les types d'échange que j'avais
avec ma mère avec des chutes
vertigineuses
et je me dis mais pourquoi elle me
raconte tout ça
et au fur et à mesure vous allez
comprendre comment le a de attitude est
venu dans ce concept de oser être
meilleur
je vois qu'on rase les cheveux de ma
mère était très fière de ses cheveux
je vois qu'elle a des douleurs mais dès
que je la regardais mais ça va elle
essaie de me faire des blagues mais
c'était vraiment les blagues du dimanche
tous les jours de la semaine quoi
qu'est-ce qui lui arrive je vois qu'elle
investit en moi à m'inscrit au foot
alors qu'elle est pas d'argent pour
m'inscrire au foot et en fait on
m'apprend quelques temps qu'elle est
décédée qu'elle monte au ciel mais moi
j'ai toujours vu digne
et celle de là qui est venu le côté où
j'ai toujours développé
les gens vont dire oui il est ultra
optimiste le a de attitude je choisis la
réponse que je donne à ce qui m'arrive
là je suis en face de vous j'ai
l'impression d'être sur un ring je
trembloque j'ai peur j'ai des émotions
mais je me donne juste comme obligation
d'être à 100 % c'est tout et ça ça vient
de ma mère ma Simone Veil à moi
le M de méthode
j'arrive
maman n'est plus là je suis en bas de
cet immeuble devant les boîtes aux
lettres et je suis pas tout seul bien
sûr on est une quinzaine parce que
regarder boîte aux lettres et je dis à
mes Brothers à mes frères vous savez
quoi dans cinq ans on disait dans 5
piges mais bon dans 5 ans je serai
champion du monde sortirai des services
sociaux je serai diplômé
moment de silence
et là tout le monde éclate de rire
mais j'avais dit hein des amis mais
vraiment des frères des têtes de Yen
j'étais devenu le Jamel Debbouze en fait
du coin quoi il manquait plus que je
mette la main dans la poche c'était
c'était on était OK et là vous savez il
y en a toujours un dedans là le plus
sage qui vient qui sort sa tête et qui
vient calme il vient vers moi
il me décoche un coup de poing au visage
et il rigole il dit mais avec ta grosse
tête là tu arrives même pas à esquiver
comment tu veux devenir champion de boxe
et là il rigole il repartent pour un
tour et là dans le M de méthode j'ai
compris qu'il fallait que je change
d'environnement il fallait que je change
et je trouve des méthodes qui me
permettraient d'accélérer les choses
parce que je commençais la box très très
tard
et avec ce m de méthode c'est ce qui m'a
permis de venir champion du monde en 4
ans et demi de récupérer ma sœur de
sortir des services sociaux de devenir
jeune majeur de pouvoir être diplômé
d'arriver à une licence alors que j'ai
commencé avec un BAFA
et donc du coup ce m de méthode avait
fonctionné
et pour la troisième histoire
c'est ni plus ni moins que celle du
départ j'arrive je suis champion du
monde ok très bien
j'ai fait en 4 ans et demi
maintenant il va falloir que je mette ça
en mouvement le a de action quand je dis
action c'est de prendre sa capacité à
vraiment mettre ses valeurs en mouvement
en énergie et donc l'une des choses que
j'ai apprises d'ailleurs et que je vais
partager avec vous tout de suite c'est
cette notion de mise en énergie de se
permettre des choses très très folles
j'ai découvert l'existence des grandes
écoles pour moi une grande école c'est
une école qui était grande de taille
c'est tout après on m'a dit bah tiens tu
peux entreprendre mais moi entreprendre
pour avoir le chiffre d'affaires et
avoir ça ne me disait pas grand chose
jusqu'à ce que j'apprenne qu'il y a des
écoles qui nous forment à
l'entrepreneuriat social et solidaire et
là je me retrouve dans l'une des écoles
dont je peux pas faire de la pub pour
les autres je pense qui m'accepte dans
son incubateur après avoir sélectionné
50 Dossiers
d'utiliser le sport comme moyen de
développer les potentiels et de
connecter mon entreprise à celui de ceux
qui sont en jeu qui veulent entreprendre
ou avoir et je me retrouve à viser des
choses folles mais qui ont du sens pour
moi
avec cette action là avec cette
dynamique là avec ce a de ama je me
retrouve à vivre des choses mais juste
extraordinaires
portez la flamme olympique me retrouver
avec l'équipe de Barack Obama aux
États-Unis à travailler des projets pour
développer l'entrepreneuriat social me
retrouver à partager et accompagner des
décideurs qui eux acceptent d'être
tuteur de jeunes d'accompagner des
entreprises à passer de la notion de
ressources humaines à développer le
potentiel humain parce que moi on a misé
sur mon potentiel
et ça avancé comme ça et là je me suis
retrouvé du coup avec ce concept de ama
en dédicace avec cette âme et en
dédicace avec toutes ces armes que j'ai
pu rencontrer avec lesquelles je me suis
connecté et là avec ce socle de mise en
énergie que je voudrais partager avec
vous est-ce que vous êtes prêts
alors ça va être simple c'est 15
secondes là je vous défie je vous
challenge
la mise en énergie j'ai découverte comme
ça j'allais dans des spectacles comme ça
sportifs et je voyais que nous français
on était très timide avec la réussite et
que le fait d'encourager nos équipes et
ça s'est avéré vrai après parce que je
me faisais Hué sur la Marseillaise
d'accord donc ça va être simple jusqu'à
ce qu'on arrive à trouver un rythme
commun je voudrais que vous fassiez
juste ça deux coups sur les cuisses et
un coup sur la main
plus fort
super super
vous pouvez vous applaudir vraiment
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
plus que jamais j'ai juste trois
questions pour terminer cette rencontre
je vous ai dit je veux pas me présenter
à vous mais vous rencontrez c'est est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut qu'on ose
juste le fait d'être meilleur d'affirmer
sa singularité qui ok avec ça
ok est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut le
faire ensemble
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut le
faire maintenant
dans ce cas là c'est moi qui vous
applaudis qui vous remercie c'était Enya
[Musique]